I'm a math nerd and this is a quick
equation to show everybody the face of
cultural appropriation congratulations
this is how it works
have you ever been eaten alive in the
form of a verse welcome I know you
thought you were at BuzzFeed today but
we are getting rid of that today we are
rap feed we rap speaking of your rap
beat one time I'm gonna explain the
rules really quick we're gonna have
three rounds MCS are gonna go
head-to-head in thirty-second rounds for
round one and round two and then the
winners of those rounds are gonna
compete in the final one-minute rap
battle before we bring the MCS up I want
to introduce our amazing judges first up
we have DJ Devastator all the way from
wildin now make some noise all the way
from beat see we have Nandi Mason
and last but certainly not least we have
our boy Kwai see what Blanc way see
y'all ready for some MCS they come up
here to spit on fire oh you can do
better than that make more noise Annette
first up we have MCS good to go and
Cameron Jordan my name is good to go I
first started rapping over punk bands
and reggae bands I would say so my hip
hop's kind of genre blending being a
white guy in hip hop is always
interesting you know you always get
double take but I've always felt that as
long as you're just being you and
emulating your story that you know
people will get my name is Cameron
Jordan I've been rapping forever as a
kid you know I didn't have really good
means to express myself so when I used
to hear beats and you know my brother
would give me record how I always
visualized myself being those kind of
rappers and it kind of just gives me an
identity to express myself through
alright good to go through this time
starts now
cool look Dawg you ain't ready footboard
to go against me you need machetes and
swords to playoffs you fall behind I
have to settle the score
get your squad I drop in i dismantle
your fort
look build know you ain't got class you
can't go against me I might miss me I
messed up but I'll care what he was so
okay got no flow you look like you
worked at Trader Joe's I liked how you
mixed in that I messed up that was a
good verse then I can always go do this
good good to go you ready to retire yeah
right here spin this yo first off let me
Burt stop I'm gonna rip this universe
off I got some dirt you want to write me
off and I'm lost but across and I got
the sales at Trader Joe's that's why I
change these episodes I got the rosetta
stone I got these rhymes you can't
decode I'm here to overload I don't
think that you know it's good to go a
free-for-all I see it all I'm here to
come and call I'm doing off the padded
balls and I'm lost in the beat but I go
within a freak and I really got to speak
if you whatever eats not gonna tell thee
but there's more to go teach if you know
that way then we gotta go freak I'm good
to go
not always cypher well that you killed
it let's check in with the judges to see
what they think
who's moving on to the next round what
do you think how do you feel about good
to go in camera you both did really good
guys I think you guys did a cool job
yeah man I love the fact that you kept
going better but it was cool I like the
fact that my man has incorporated his
mess up into his around that was
definitely that's how you know he was
going off the top it wasn't written I
did like the cadence a good two goes
though he was rocketing he was really
trying to show that he could speak he
had the versatility boats a million is a
battle a decision has to be made on the
count of three judges let us know who
you think won this first round one two
three kam so looks like kam is moving on
to round two baby bear thank you so much
good to go let's bring out the suave and
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all like the shampoo bus was paying
to you I've been doing music my whole
life like since I was a little kid like
my mom had like bought a Mac and I just
like start making songs on garage bands
I see what's about to happen yeah whoa
hey smoking weight of pain take a
lighter lift up hey he got my kid no no
little Club yeah
why you talking boy on bunch of drips
all talking about it but you know you
can handle look look tense hos deep and
I'm really in it beat every time I hit
it you know we talking in the street put
little holes up in the hidden layer she
ain't no suave here's a brief you know
put in another digital dash
[Applause]
so many bars alright so we're gonna
we're gonna check in with the judges
real quick and see how they feel a
Devastator how do you feel about the rap
battle that just happened really going
at each other in a very like lyrical way
they weren't really dropping a lot of
bombs on each other but they were trying
to show their prowess so give them
respect for that I think both y'all rode
the beat let's go play some swabs like
yo fear flow was like for every kid born
after 1998 I think we ready on the count
of 3 1 2 3 let's bring up Austin kita I
was involved in all sorts of arts
programs in my hometown of Laurel
Maryland I think music is important for
a lot of reasons on some non Kanye type
stuff it's a closed thing we have to
reach in the intangible because there's
a lot of things you can reach forward I
say like love happy sad you understand
that music can convey parts that you
don't get music is the closest thing we
have to Sonic painting my name is Keenan
the first from st. Paul Minnesota and
I'm here to eat some rappers for dessert
lunch and dinner like entrees I've been
riding since I was 12 just started
producing within the last year and I've
been doing a lot more singing actually
than rapping but we still here to eat
some rappers today this is my rap of
faith ready I guess so let's do it let's
do this yo I'm about to treat this
battle like a bar I'm just giving you
straight rounds your face says never let
me come near a playground so I see it
homie and I can really trust that you
need to get that mustache right like a
bus pass I'm so up in my zone
you look like Macaulay Culkin when
frozen home alone I'm a you look as so
old-school do you have a rotary or a
mobile phone they don't matter you know
you don't got balls you left those
scrotum home
I'm bringing bacon I've run the nation
yes
Austin that's my statement that's my
time are you for you okay so remember he
came here to eat
so let's not caramel right yeah I
respect you for coming up on his stage
but why'd you do it with different
colored shoes silver and beige hold up
Austin yeah he came from Texas what the
hell is going on with show necklace okay
um yeah he said my moustache looking
weird but hold up let me make this clear
this dude got what the heck is going on
up under here okay I'm heating up first
I do this every single day I eat these
rappers and they're not going ate
dessert I try to tell them what it's
like I'm gonna put them under light and
even if I had to take his life I had to
get the nurse time I feel you feel it
feel it all right judges let's hear what
you guys think her uh right right
whatever crazy boss they said yes -
can't be on a playground something like
that that was crazy
I mean you went off it was definitely a
great bathroom looking forward to you
eating rapper not sure if you did but
that this was great I like that he took
his hat off and expose what was going on
a Bundy they're both simile this is a
battle and and obviously one person
we're harder than the other so you know
which way it gonna have to go judges on
the count of three one two three yeah
I'll see you are moving on
alright everybody we got the last battle
for the first round everybody ready give
it up for Shannon and blonde q hi I'm
Shannon I'm a little nervous I don't
feel like I'm the most confident rapper
but I've been working on my freestyles a
little bit we'll see if they're you know
up to par with these other guys my name
is Blanco it's time for me to really
step out as an artist and I'm just
grateful for the opportunity to really
showcase what I've been working on
really the almost last 10 years of my
life on a pump let's do it a first lady
MC yeah I mean how does that feel to be
up here I love it representing I'm up
here I'm gonna have fun I'm just gonna
be confident with it that's all I don't
really know how I got into the but your
face you kind of look like the clown
from it you got a blazer on right now
you gonna do my taxes I don't know I got
some money back so maybe you can help me
with that I'm not trying to relaxants
what you got a dolphin on your necklace
may get some silver chain I got this in
Mexico I can help you out if you want me
though I'm rocking some car [ __ ] songs
but I'm looking at those and I'm like
what the hell are those I was in middle
school probably I don't know you got
some product in your hair it's gonna
flip back at me yeah that's it alright
Blanc you ready to respond yeah I'm
ready okay oh god yeah yeah okay
yo that's what's cool but I forgot what
you said why does it look like you got a
mop on your head now wait I'm not saying
it's a wig don't tempt me I'm going past
crazy and now hold up I'm getting lazy
let me get back to the facts man your
whole style is rubble why am i up here
battling mrs. Huxtable hold up where's
the doctor
I Spit it with the 90s flow it's
unbelievable I'm GI Joe with the kung fu
grip I'm acid tip to your throat just
because you got pretty lips don't mean
you can't catch the kids to death
I'll come through no disrespect
Wow oh okay this thing is I don't know
what to say we're just gonna see what
the judges have to say yeah I might need
a little more time to deliberate I
definitely big shannon's awkward bars
that was cool up but she was coming for
his neck though like no throw punches
he'll and uh my man's over here came
just like Wall Street stunning like I'll
rock with that man I'm gonna need some
time to deliberate
I love funk you I loved your confidence
and the compliment you threw in that was
great
Shannon i luvs you awkward bars as well
cool so judges on the count of three one
two three
whoo all right blonde Q you are moving
on to the next round I had to add you to
Matt - we will see you in the next round
well that is it for round one we're
gonna move into round two stay tuned
all right everybody are you ready for
the next round another 30 second round
with the winners from round one you all
ready ready
yes so let's make some noise for suave
and Cameron Jordan all right
look look look wax on wax off I can
already tell all these wraps are soft oh
he's lost for words I'm gonna call you
mr. soft-serve look I'm on Appa Mac you
a das nerd you outdated so you're mixed
tape on that Pippa didn't play as a
person beeps come on I didn't make it
cause I really hate come on doggy why
you gotta come and get me
you might as well act like the Frog is
asleep look it's your hair dog it's a
rainbow you got tired of clothes dog and
he's changed oh come on dog you any
change flows how'd you got kool-aid on
your Jordans come on why you coming
sporting yeah whoa yeah new generation
number nineties baby you're stepping in
this better use me for you crazy got it
down a minute is she so lazy yeah look
at all these genial you must be crazy
walking out of the house looking like a
bum
sock Oh stepping on the move and gum got
down and I'm beating up this beat like a
drunk he's talking be mature will not be
Redrum oh my god
cut though cut the hell is there like
hey you're not ready back can I run it
back we'll talk to the producers and
I'll see if we can run it down got a
the laws bro hey hey let's see hey
follow me on Spotify you know saying get
that out the music anything can happen
anything is possible so judges how do
you feel about what we just witnessed
here with Cameron and swap hey just say
less alright cams moving on got it got
it thank you so much swap for being here
alright y'all ready for the next round
give it up for Austin and blonde cute
[Applause]
let me find my life huh let me find my
life right yo yo I'm a math nerd and
this is a quick equation to show
everybody the face of cultural
appropriation congratulations this is
how it works have you ever been eaten
alive in the form of a verse
honestly yo I got to tell you that's a
lie you're so wack you're probably the
reason biggie died so don't ever say his
name I'm making magic I'm David Blaine
you body's fake as Dana Dane so here's
how it goes people making fun of my
chunks if that's the case then you done
up on a chipper up matter of fact you're
faking dawg I hit you with the
fisticuffs no I'm keeping the chill I
don't need me a deal honestly you lost
the Queen Latifah's last round for rails
he did not have to go appropriate he
didn't block you oh yeah yeah you ready
to respond all right Courtney spin it
yeah yeah yeah hey oh can you turn it up
yeah I let my light shine
I ain't fake by your rhymes you fake by
design I look through your lines I've
seen it you met foot hold up I had to
mix it up with the soda wait wait you
want to talk about that you're really
great but let me elevate you can't
really do what I'd say
I equate that your equations a bunch of
fakes they got disproved about 10 years
ago because CMM came through what the
illness flow may be better than biggie
but it ain't no biggie I'll come through
and get jiggy like Will Smith did but I
really can with your buckwheat head hold
up you little rascal I might put you
under our armpit because it looks like
your mom did she should can't we're
gonna see what the judges have to say
about this I'm gonna love when they come
out swinging like that that's what I
want to see this is a battle that's how
it's supposed to go down I love that
that's it
y'all came yeah wasn't that wasn't
playing and we loved it
Showtime yeah you guys are great judges
we ready on the count of three one two
three all right Austin looks like you're
moving on to the final round
thank you all right we are ready for the
final round it's about to go down
everybody's messy the cookies in the
title of rat feed King welcome back to
the stage Austin and kam one minute you
ready
one minute huh different color converse
Wrangler jeans and a nice flow but the
hair you look like black Johnny Bravo
come on crunchy you can't touch me no
you think this whole style is a little
dusty I see you touching kids like you
Sandusky it's that old bay how is that
tattered come on dog
you bout to get battered you think he
wrapped like mr. Mathers but you're not
slim no I never my need to get in the
gym look how many rappers are gonna eat
them they eat slow down on that week's
fan here they get into the gym
damn you being above the rand is that
amethyst all I even know how you
amateurs getting a rap game and speed
where the beat goes all about to bring
it back this rack you look like you're
smoking crack on the back oh yeah yeah
Austin you ready as ready as I'll ever
be I'm right
yo I got a minute so I feel like I
should go my hardest right now but I'm a
chilled cuz I'm an artist right now you
see the way I float talk about my attire
hell yeah but I get lit cuz I'm gonna
fire you now this guy yeah man you can
trust me tell everybody a BuzzFeed you
just got body by buckwheat damn ain't
that crazy don't ain't it crazy that a
bi G got the slim shady flow that you
would set before I got hella metaphors
it doesn't matter homie you look like a
predator matter of fact that's true man
you're a true loser matter of fact you
look like a mix between a youtuber and a
school shooter so you trying to make fun
of me Dawg you ain't got the buzz I'm
the real Bumblebee now I got chucks on
that's true
because I have fashioned unlike you
black dude my brother my brother what
are you trying to be a mix of a white
guy and Donald Glover awesome that's the
way going pronto I'm pulling ladies hell
yeah call me Johnny Bravo top so moving
all in head honcho matter of fact i
black out wait no I vote Blanco huh
Blanca
y'all shocking them I'm rocking them it
doesn't even matter I'd be Rock'em
Sock'em bopping them by the way on this
thing is gonna linger on behalf of lil
uzi 6 9 here's my middle finger
I'm gonna come in with the fraidy flow
the Slim Shady flow I said it before but
it doesn't matter yeah big that's what
put your ass up on a platter and I
munched it up for no discussion I run
[ __ ]
matter of fact homie I ain't lunch and
I'm Tim Duncan on the beat
I'm taking my moment and yeah I don't
got a lot homie I'm gonna own it no I'm
going so hard and steady I'm better on
your breath five balance you got mom's
sphaghetti trying to act like Eminem huh
I ain't gonna fake your this minutes
going forever alright great
the thing is quasi literally has lost
your shoes I don't know if we have a
camera on this we're gonna check it with
the judges one last time and see if see
what they have to say yeah but sometimes
yes initial thoughts what do we I don't
I don't know Nandi any thoughts right
now initially I mean we just went
through a lot after yeah yeah yeah
that's all I got kWe see you lost the
shoes are you back you good gays guys
look great man
on the count of three judges one two
three
Austin is the king of rap beat Austin
whoa you just you killed it up here
thank you
how do you feel like it doesn't feel to
win Rafi it's still it's still kicking
in you know like if anybody's out there
he's like young rappers coming up like
someone who's looking up to you right
now what would you say to them
I would say that I if you really Bible
what I'm doing that means is you vibe
with yourself so keep doing exactly what
you're doing and keep motivating me and
I motivate you just right back thank you
all so much for coming out Austin you
killed it and I thank you so much judges
DJ Devastator Nandi Mason and kwazy
thank you so much for being here
[Music]